- Welcome back, everybody.
I want to give a
particular shout out
to people who are
watching us on the web.
We've got quite an audience.
Everything from people who are
local, here in Massachusetts,
to--
let me let me read
some of them--
Corpus Christi, Texas,
Norman, Oklahoma.
And we've also got
international viewers in Lima,
in Rio, Geneva, Montreal, Corfu,
Greece, Queretaro, Mexico,
Zagreb, Croatia, and
Ulaanbaatar, Mongolia.
So welcome to all of you.
Our next speaker
is Kevin Esvelt,
who's an assistant professor
of the MIT Media Lab, where
he leads the Sculpting
Evolution Group in exploring
evolutionary and
ecological engineering.
He helped pioneer the
development of CRISPR,
which you may know as
a powerful new method
of genome engineering.
In 2013, he was the first
to identify the potential
for CRISPR gene drive, which
you'll learn about, to alter
wild populations of organisms.
With island communities
in Nantucket
and Martha's Vineyard,
they're advancing
the Mice Against
Ticks Project, which
aims to prevent tick-borne
disease, such as Lyme.
An outspoken advocate of
freely sharing research
plans to accelerate
discovery and improve safety,
Dr. Esvelt seeks
to use gene drive
as a catalyst to reform
the scientific ecosystem.
Please join me in
welcoming Kevin Esvelt.
[APPLAUSE]
- All right, thank you
so much for the kind
introduction and the
invitation to speak today.
So how many of you here today
have been bitten by a tick?
Please raise your hand.
Yeah-- see, I'm
from the west coast,
so I find this horrifying.
I mean, up in
Washington State, you
wander around in
the forest all day
and you'll never get
bitten by a tick.
There won't be any
attached to your clothing.
In fact, I never saw
one, growing up there.
And so you come out here
and it's just take a walk
in the woods and they're
crawling and it's-- ugh.
But that is bad
enough, of course.
I mean, and there are
mosquitoes everywhere.
But with ticks, of course,
they can give you disease.
Now mosquitoes can too, but here
in the United States, at least,
tick-borne disease is actually
the number one vector-borne
disease--
specifically, it's Lyme disease.
Please raise your
hand if you had Lyme.
Yeah, quite a few--
too many.
So tick-borne
disease is a problem
that we have, to some
extent, brought on ourselves.
The CDC now estimates
that there is
upwards of 300,000 cases in
the United States a year.
And when I say we've
brought it on ourselves,
it's because we have engineered
the local environment
to maximize the incidence
of tick-borne disease.
How have we done that?
Well, we love forests.
We like trees.
So we plant trees.
And in fact, around here,
it's actually more forested
than it's been in a long time.
But we also build
roads and houses,
of course, so we can get
around in our lovely forests,
and that means we've maximized
the forest perimeter.
And forest perimeter favors
deer, and white-footed mice.
Now every deer, every
adult deer, has typically,
2,000 to 5,000 ticks
attached to it.
And every adult female tick will
lay a couple of thousand eggs.
So every deer is a million
ticks in the next generation.
So we've maximized
the number of deer.
The only effective predator
these days is the automobile,
and that means we've
maximized the number of ticks.
But even worse, ticks
bite three times,
and usually, it's small
mammals, small mammal--
deer.
Now of the small mammals,
the white-footed mouse
is the best reservoir for every
form of tick-borne disease.
That is, tick bites a mouse,
if the tick's infected,
the mouse pretty much
always gets infected,
if it's a white-footed mouse.
That's not true for the other
things that ticks might bite,
and the same is true when a
infected mouse gets bitten
by an uninfected tick.
The tick pretty much always
gets infected with the pathogen
that causes Lyme.
So we have maximized
the number of mice
and the number of
ticks, and therefore,
the number of infected
ticks, and this is a problem
that we created.
That's why 100 years
ago, you people really
hadn't heard of
tick-borne disease.
It's not because it wasn't
there, it was just very rare.
So this is why we
have a problem.
It's not just Lyme
disease, of course--
Borrelia burgdorferi is
the cause of Lyme disease.
There are other
forms of Borrelia.
There's also Babezia and
Anaplasma and Ehrlichia.
And there's even a couple
of viruses, namely Powassan,
which is truly terrifying.
But they're all passed
between white-footed mice
and the black-legged ticks.
It's an ecological cycle, back
and forth between the two.
And we would not care,
except for the fact
that an infected tick can, of
course, bite us and give us
disease and our pets disease.
Incidentally, our pets have
a vaccine and we don't.
How fair is that?
It used to be on the
market for humans,
but it was withdrawn at the very
beginning of the vaccine scare.
And now there is no vaccine
for humans for Lyme disease,
and there was never one,
and there is not one
in development for
any of the others.
And the incidence of all
them, of course, is rising.
And the others are actually more
dangerous than Lyme disease,
for the most part.
So we have this
simple idea of what
would happen if we built
a shield around the mice.
What if the mice could
not become infected?
Well, you would disrupt
this ecological cycle
of transmission and you'd
have fewer ticks, fewer
infected ticks and fewer
cases of human disease--
probably, given the importance
of the mice, a lot fewer.
This is the premise
behind Mice Against Ticks.
We want to enlist
the mice to fight
ticks and tick-borne disease.
So it says here it's
a community effort
to prevent tick-borne disease.
And this is based around
a simple question--
how do you engineer
a wild population
of white-footed mice?
There's a lot of
mice in the woods.
How are you going
to immunize them?
You're going to
catch them one-by-one
and jab them with a needle?
This is clearly
not going to fly.
You need something else.
We need to actually
engineer their DNA
so that they are immune
and can pass that immunity
onto future generations of
mice, because we don't want
to release hundreds
of thousands,
or millions of mice in
the woods every season.
Because they have five
or so generations a year.
The solution is you
look at an island,
because there's probably a
billion mice on the mainland,
but on say, Martha's Vineyard,
there's maybe 100,000, at most,
in the spring, at
the end of winter.
There is maybe 800,000 at
the beginning of winter.
That's how much it fluctuates.
So if you introduced, say,
100,000 mice in the spring,
then you'd be introducing
as many mice as are there.
And if these introduced
mice had resistance genes,
then they would pass them
down to future generations
and most future mice
would inherit one.
And because it's an island, you
don't have this constant influx
and interbreeding of wild mice.
And the same goes for Nantucket.
But of course, if
you're proposing
to do anything like this,
not only are you proposing
to genetically engineer a
wild population, which is,
I understand, a little
bit controversial.
But you really are
doing a different kind
of research than pretty
much anything else,
with the arguable
exception of public health,
just because you are changing
the shared environment.
That is, your research is
intended to affect everyone.
So please raise your hand if
you don't have a smartphone.
Yes, there are a few people.
It is possible to live
without a smartphone.
You can opt out of
having a smartphone,
but you cannot opt out
of breathing the air,
or drinking the water,
consuming the fruit of the land.
And this is why people are
sensitive about these things.
Because if you are proposing to
develop a technology intended
to alter that, it will
necessarily affect everyone,
and they cannot opt out.
And that means if you do this
work behind closed doors,
as virtually all
science is done,
then you are denying
them a voice in decisions
that will affect them.
We have fought long and hard
for some form of representation
in government.
And yet now, because technology
is allowing us to do things
like this, scientists
are undertaking
projects that will affect
people as much as legislation
passed by duly-elected
representatives.
And they're doing it in
secret, where the people cannot
possibly have a voice
in those decisions.
So we decided OK, if we're
even going to consider this,
we need to do it differently.
We need to not only
cherry-pick our problems, which
is one reason why we're
looking at tick-borne disease.
You want to address something
that people care about
and it's obviously
an issue to everyone.
But you want to share
your proposals before you
do anything in the lab.
Before you do
anything at all, you
want to go to the communities
and say, all right,
we think this is a problem.
But you're the
ones who live here.
Do you think it's a problem?
And here are the different
ways that we think
we might be able to address it.
Ideally, lay out several
of them, and say,
what do you think of these?
We want to hear from everyone,
including vocal skeptics.
I love vocal skeptics
because they're not
afraid to stand up and tell
me that is a terrible idea.
And as long as
they're willing to say
why that's a
terrible idea, that's
fantastic because there's always
a chance, often a good chance,
that they may have thought of
something that none of us has.
And that means that we
have a chance of fixing it
before we actually do it.
In fact, before we
even develop anything.
You don't want the
public comment period
to be at the end of the
technology development cycle.
You want it at the
very, very beginning
so you can address
things from the get-go.
So you not only want
to invite concerns,
you want to invite
community guidance.
And in fact, we decided
to go further than this.
We decided that the communities,
it's their environment.
They need to be in control.
They need to govern the project.
They need to have the power
to say 'no' at any point,
and then we walk away.
That is, we are just
the technical hands.
They are in the driver's seat.
And by the way, we can
be the technical hands,
but we can't be the
technical assessors,
because we're biased, right?
Who's the last person
you want to test
a scientific hypothesis?
It's the person who proposed it.
They're the single most biased
individual in the entire world.
Why do we do science
the way we do, again?
Oh right, apparently no one
thought that one through.
But the same is
true of technology.
You don't want me to evaluate
whether this is a good idea,
looking at the field trial data
and so on, because I cannot
help but be biased.
I am human.
This is how we are built.
You need independent assessors
to take a look at this.
And so, this is what we're
going to have to have.
The communities are
going to contract
with an independent group, maybe
the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences down the road,
maybe the National Academies,
to, essentially, appoint a
group of independent researchers
to evaluate this step-by-step
and give the report
to the communities, who then
will eventually vote on whether
or not to move forwards.
So how would it work?
Well, if you take mice,
we then immunize them
against various
things using vaccines,
just by exposing them to ticks--
bunch of different
ways of doing it.
And if you do this
to a bunch of mice,
then you will get
mice, some mice,
that are resistant to
whatever you expose them to.
Their immune systems
will evolve and produce
antibodies that can bind, and
are protective against whatever
we expose them to.
We can then do b-cell sorting--
there's a few
other methods, too,
but this is the
one we settled on--
to identify antibody-encoding
genes produced
by those individual
resistant mice.
We can then make those
antibodies in the lab
and test them, both in the
dish and in the animals,
verify that they actually
are protective against what
we want, and then
we can encode them.
This is the neat trick.
We can encode those genes
taken from some mice
into the germline
genome, that is,
the cells that will lead the
sperm and egg production,
so that those genes
taken from a few mice
will be passed on to
future generations.
This is not something that our
immune systems normally do.
That is, we get a cold.
Sadly, our kids are not
immune to every cold
we've ever gotten.
That would be lovely,
that's not how it works.
But in the lab now, that
we have tools like CRISPR,
we can actually do that.
So we can make mice
that are born secreting
protective antibodies.
We're looking at doing
it from the liver,
because the liver secretes
all sorts of stuff
in your bloodstream.
So they just have
these extra copies
of antibody-encoding
genes that the liver
would secrete from birth,
providing resistance.
And then once you
have these mice
and they look resistant to
whatever we're immunizing them
against them in the lab,
and that it's heritable,
then you need to test it, and
that involves a field trial
on a small, probably
mostly uninhabited island,
off the coast somewhere.
And then you have the assessment
over a couple of years.
Look at everything people think
of that they're afraid might go
wrong in the ecosystem, and a
few things that they haven't.
And the independent assessor
team delivers a report.
And on the basis of that,
the communities vote--
good old New England town
hall democracy-style--
propose a warrant at the
town meeting, and they vote.
And on the Vineyard, of course,
because mice will move all over
the island, presumably, all
six towns have to vote 'yes.'
Nantucket will be
just the one vote.
And then that would involve
releasing hundreds of thousands
of, potentially, of
genetically-engineered mice
on the Nantucket Vineyard.
I bet none of you ever
thought you might see that.
But there are rules
when you are working
with biology, because
evolution likes complexity.
If you make sure
that things connect
to lots of other
different things,
then you're very evolvable.
A lot of potential mutations
can change things and then
be adaptive, and so that's why
evolution seems to like this.
But it makes it bloody
difficult to engineer,
because you tweak one
thing and it changes
a bunch of other things.
And if this is true
within an organism,
within a cell, how much
worse is it in an ecosystem?
So the general
rule is be humble.
But that's not a
very useful rule.
We need to be more
specific than that.
So I have-- you should
try to make the smallest
possible change that can
solve whatever problem you're
interested in, and
you need to start
local and small, small-scale.
See if it works, and only
then scale up if warranted.
And so that's-- this is
why we do field trials.
Now what is the
problem in this case?
What are we going to
immunize the mice against?
And here is where
there's different options
and different ways
of going about it.
Option number one
is, say, Lyme disease
is the most common problem.
We can immunize them
against the Lyme pathogen,
just like the vaccine does, and
they will generate antibodies.
We can then make
those inheritable
and protect all the mice against
Lyme disease, specifically,
and therefore, us.
That would be minimally--
that would be a
minimal intervention
because we don't think
Lyme disease does
much-- ecologically-speaking it
wouldn't effect anything else.
The other option is to immunize
the mice against the ticks.
That is, the tick
has to suppress
the mouse's immune
system in order
to remain attached to its
host for several days.
If you immunize the
organism against
the tick's
immunosuppressive proteins,
which is sort of its
invisibility shield--
if you say that the
immune system, hey,
you might get bitten by a tick,
and if so, they have this neat
invisibility shield
that they'll construct,
but if you catch it early,
here's what it looks like--
and then the immune system
attacks and destroys
that key
immunosuppressive protein.
And then it can see the
tick, and in what can only be
described as a miracle, this
molecular-level immune response
can somehow make
the mouse taste bad,
and so the ticket will fall off,
like it's bitten into some--
I don't know-- habanero sauce.
So we asked the communities
what they wanted
and the pretty much
universal answer--
there were a bare handful of
people in the couple of percent
that said one or the other--
but virtually,
everybody said, look,
if you're going to do
it at all, just do both.
Throw the kitchen sink at 'em.
Because people said the problem
is not just Lyme disease,
it's all of the other diseases.
And option one wouldn't
do anything for those.
But above all else, we are sick
of having so bloody many ticks
in the woods.
If you can reduce
the number of ticks
back to the way it was 50
years ago, that would be great.
And so they want to do both.
However, there is a caveat--
no matter how much you
tell people that you know--
raise your hand if you
ate beef in the last week?
Please, everyone.
Did you know that the
cow genome is 25% snake?
It's true.
Gene transfer event,
probably tick-mediated,
about a million or
so years ago, spread
a virus that included a jumping
gene from snakes that then
replicated in the
[? oroc ?] genome,
and it was inherited by cows.
So cows are 25% snake.
Genes move between
species all the time.
Specie is an arbitrary concept.
But that doesn't
matter because people
are leery of moving
DNA between species.
And it's their environment,
so they're in control.
So they said, don't
use any foreign DNA.
Which we can still do, remember,
because that mouse-adaptive
immune response produces
resisting-antibodies
in the mice.
So now the project is run
by a steering committee,
one for each island appointed
by the boards of health.
And in the lab, we now
have anti-Lyme antibodies
from white-footed mice,
and we've immunized
mice against the tick protein.
And next, we need to verify
that all of these antibodies
work, and the tests to
develop genome editing,
because no one's done
that in white-footed mice.
The steering committees,
on behalf of the islands,
are going to apply for
regulatory approval
for field trials, which is
going to be a novel approach.
It's not going to
the scientists,
it's going to be
the communities.
And hopefully, we will
identify suitable small islands
for trials.
There's a bunch of
candidates and people
are very interested in that.
So to be clear though,
this is many years away.
The earliest possible release
on Nantucket or the Vineyard
would be 2024.
But that doesn't
help most of you.
Some of you may well live on
Nantucket, in the vineyard.
I don't know.
But probably most of you don't,
even if you may visit there.
So how do you alter a
population of mainland mice.
There's like a billion
of them, right?
You're just not going
to rear that many.
You got to spread those
antibody genes somehow.
And here is where
gene drive comes in.
So CRISPR is a molecular
scalpel that we
can use to cut and
therefore, edit
pretty much any gene
in any organism where
we can get the DNA in.
So you introduce
CRISPR, but you actually
encode the CRISPR system
for doing genome editing
into the genome
itself, along with,
in this case, the antibodies.
So then CRISPR cuts the
target, copies itself in.
You now have a resistant mouse.
But you also have
a mouse that knows
how to make the CRISPR
system, and so it
will cut the other
chromosome, copy itself over.
So now this mouse
has two copies,
which means that when it
mates, all of its offspring
are going to inherit.
And in those offspring,
genome editing
is going to happen again.
It's going to cut the wild
type version inherited
from the other parent, and
it's going to copy itself over.
Meaning when those mice
mate, the next generation--
everybody's going to
inherit, and the next
and the next and the next.
So we pointed out that this
could be done with CRISPR,
I guess, three years
ago now, publicly.
And it was pretty
obvious that this
could save millions of lives
because tick-borne disease is
one thing, it's what
we care about here.
But obviously, we've heard about
much more terrible epidemics,
and the most obvious
one is malaria.
So in the time that
I've been speaking,
malaria has killed
probably 10 children
and infected 5,000 people.
So conceivably,
one could use this
to immunize all of the malarial,
the major malaria vectors,
particularly in Africa.
That raises a lot
of moral issues.
But it's not just malaria.
Schistomiasis also has infected
even more people, possibly
6,000 to 7,000 people,
and has killed somewhere
between two and five, probably.
We're not quite sure.
This is true even
though you have
praziquantel, which is a
perfect cure that costs pennies.
The problem is this
bad even though we
have a perfect cure
that costs pennies,
because people just
get re-infected.
But with the gene drive,
we could potentially
target and eliminate
[? schistosomes ?]
responsible directly.
But nothing is ever easy.
Again, should we be
doing this in secret?
This is way worse than
just making resistant mice,
where you have to release
hundreds of thousands of them.
This is something
where you release a few
and it effects on an
entire wild population.
Should we be doing
this in secret?
I mean, we thought, no.
So we pretty much flew in the
face of scientific tradition
and said, hey, we
we've been working
with CRISPR for a while, we
know this is going to work.
It's the same mechanism.
Here's how it could
work, and we think
we should tell people before
we actually try it in the lab.
So that's what we did.
And since then, we have
been pre-registering
all of our experiments.
That is, we detail what
we're going to do and why,
and what safeguards
we're using in advance
so that people have time to
comment before we actually
do them.
And this approach strikes
people as reasonable.
I have yet to encounter anyone
who says, oh, no, that's
a horrible idea.
You shouldn't do that.
And the National Academies
had a report on gene drive
that agreed that the
best course of action
is to ensure that those
who would be affected
have an opportunity to
have a voice, of course.
And yet somehow, they
didn't quite draw that--
you connect the
dots to this means
that research needs
to be done in the open
so that people can have a voice.
Because that would be
inconvenient, you see.
That would require researchers
to do something different.
That would require you to
share your brilliant idea
with everybody else,
and thereby run the risk
that someone else might publish
it first and harm your career.
Never mind, are people likely
to trust us to even develop
this technology and
potentially use it
if we're doing it in
secret because we're
concerned for our careers?
Color me a little bit skeptical.
And despite the fact
that everybody publicly
agrees that this is
probably what we should do,
It's one of those cases where
nobody actually does anything
to support this.
They just all voice
support and then
hope that maybe somebody
else will do something.
And even the
scientists would love
to live in a different world
where we weren't punished
for sharing what we're doing,
but systems are hard to change.
So we're trying.
There's four main levers
over scientific practices--
IP, journals, funders,
and policymakers.
Problem is, journals, funders,
and policymakers are all
collective action problems.
Nobody wants to do anything
unless everybody else does too,
at the same time.
So I'm interested in this
concept of ethical licensing,
and this will only happen if
the universities are brave,
specifically, your
local universities.
So if you have ties
to Harvard or MIT,
guess who has a lot
of patents involving
CRISPR and CRISPR gene drive?
So we're talking to them and
to the Broad, for example,
in Berkeley about--
can we perhaps use
those to say, we'll
give anybody who wants
it, a research license
to use these technologies
to develop gene drive
systems for free.
But only if you preregister,
only if the work
is done in the open.
That's the requirement.
That's the idea.
Hopefully, it'll work.
But people often ask me,
well, why do you care?
Now there's a great
webcomic written by a guy
from Somerville, Randall
Munroe, called xkcd,
and this came out last week.
And it pretty much
explains very well
why I, in particular, care.
So this plots different
fields of research by the risk
that your research will be used
by a super villain for world
domination, by the risk
of the thing you're
studying breaking free
from your facility
and threatening the
local population.
And my laboratory works
in the areas up here,
so this is why I'm concerned.
And I think we can all agree
that if genetic engineering is
there on the plot, gene drive is
somewhere up and to the right.
So that's what I do.
This is why I'm concerned.
But more generally,
I have to say,
I think the world would
be a better place if all
researchers-- if we all held
ourselves morally responsible
for all the consequences
of our work, all of it--
intended and unintended.
And we can't
anticipate everything,
so we should be
inviting everyone
to tell us how we might be
wrong, because science doesn't
work by some magic method.
Science works by setting up
the incentives for other people
to prove us wrong,
and that should not
be limited to
professional scientists.
The real problems, though,
are invasiveness and trust.
We've done some simulations
led by Chuck Noble.
If you introduce a gene drive
into one population that's
connected to others, it takes
a very, very low migration rate
for it to spread.
And this is driven home by if
you simulate the worst gene
drive system published
to date, if you introduce
a handful of organisms into
a population a few dozen,
say, fruit flies, that carry
this worst possible gene
drive described to date, it
takes off in a new population.
So first of all, if
this thing gets out--
laboratory accident-- it starts
turning an entire species
around the world into GMOs.
You think people
are going to support
using this against malaria?
Are Africans really going
to vote in favor of that?
If we accidentally edit
all the fruit flies, say?
So we tried to prevent this.
Unfortunately, no matter
how much publicity you get,
there's always some
scientists who don't see it.
And we were very afraid that
someone might independently
decide hey, wouldn't
it be cool that insert
CRISPR into the genome
because then we can knock out
both copies at once.
That'd be a great
laboratory tool, right?
And not even think
about the possibility
that it might
spread in the wild.
And sure enough,
exactly that happened,
into something
horrific, to boot.
But we got together with them
and a bunch of other people
and agreed on necessary
laboratory safeguards.
And as best we can tell,
there's didn't get out.
So I think we're OK.
But the real problem
is that there also
means there is no such
thing as a safe field trial.
You cannot start local
and scale up if warranted.
You cannot know what the effect
is going to be of your actual
gene drive system of this kind,
because you try it anywhere,
and the odds are it's going
to spread to every population
of that species in the world.
And you can talk about
your very isolated island
hosting only a military
installation all you want.
But Australia was testing a
rabbit hemorrhagic disease
and it got off of their island
and it spread in Australia.
And then New Zealand said
no, we don't want that.
You didn't study it well enough.
And New Zealand farmers
smuggled it in any way
through the tightest
biosecurity in the world.
Do you think that people
won't move organisms
around the world?
Let's look at history.
And of course, that also means
that every nation harboring
the target species must
agree in advance to do this.
Now there is a great
organization, Target Malaria,
led by Austin Burt,
who first proposed
using gene drive to combat
malaria, in particular.
And they're doing their best.
They are working with
multiple African countries
and scientists on the
ground, and trying
to ensure that Africans can
lead the development and testing
of non-drive equivalence.
But they need to get
everybody to agree,
and that's a tough one.
It might be possible
for malaria,
almost certainly not
for schistosomiasis
unless the malaria goes first.
And for [INAUDIBLE] that
spread dengue and Zika,
and Chikungunya yellow fever--
forget about it.
More than 100 country's
harboring more than 4 billion
people live with
those mosquitoes,
and they would all be
affected, so no way.
So what can you do?
I'm running out of
time, but we need
to make a local drive system.
One that does not
spread forever.
And since the problem is
it has everything it needs,
you need to split up
those drive components
so that they are limiting.
So the idea is you
separate this into what
we call a Daisy-chain
drive, because
these different
components are spread
across different chromosomes.
And they're related
to each other.
So say C causes B to be copied.
That is, B only drives
in the presence of C,
and A only drives in
the presence of B.
But C is a normal
engineered gene.
It's inherited
normally, which means
if you have an organism that
has two copies of C and B
and A of the drive,
and it mates, then
since there's two
copies of all of them,
all the offspring inherit.
But some of them
only inherit one--
but of course, then
we inherit one copy
and then C doesn't drive.
So this organism doesn't have
C. Note that the daisy chain is
shorter.
And when it mates,
some of it's offspring
no longer have B, which
means in the next generation,
you actually have
descendants that don't
inherit the primary change.
So this means that it's local.
Every daisy link in this chain
is like a form of genetic fuel.
They will run out over time,
just due to normal inheritance,
until it stops.
And it's a built-in limit.
There's only so many.
And if you give them more,
it will be more powerful.
It will spread for
longer before it stops.
And that's useful
because we don't
want to have to release
that many organisms.
That's costly and we
are resource-limited.
So if you have a
90% homing drive,
which is on the low
end for mosquitoes.
Most mosquito drives
worked better than this.
Then you'd have to release
one edited mosquito say,
per 50 wild ones within your
town, which is not too bad.
If you have 98% copying
efficiency, which
is on lines with the African
malarial mosquito experiments
today, then, it's one per
500, which is even better.
But what if, say,
Cambridge wanted
to do this and
Somerville didn't,
in terms of immunizing
mice now, I'm thinking.
How do you deal with that?
How do you teach the mice
not to go across the line?
Well, the answer is you
teach the genes to vote.
So specifically, you
invoke natural selection
to favor whichever is in the
majority, either engineered
or wild-type.
And we think we can do this in
the context of the daisy drive
by introducing
this quorum effect.
So the idea is you release
your daisy drive organisms
in the center of town.
It spreads out to affect
the local town population,
and there it's in the majority.
And so when the daisy
elements run out,
the quorum effect
causes it to be selected
for against the wild-type.
But outside of town,
engineered is in the minority
and so natural selection
acts to eliminate them.
So then selection will
actually reinforce
our arbitrary invisible
political boundaries,
because they'll
actually be reflected
in the genetic frequency.
This is super theoretical.
It looks good in the models.
It looks pretty good in
some of the very preliminary
experiments.
But it's very theoretical.
But this is our best
attempt at getting
this technology in a form
where it might actually
be useful without having to get
everybody to agree in advance.
And this is why I
think it's important
that we have projects
like Mice Against Ticks,
because the other problem is
that public perception issue.
On Nantucket and the Vineyard,
a lot of people have PhDs.
More importantly, that just
means that pretty much everyone
knows someone who they trust who
has enough technical expertise
to assess what we're doing.
It's much harder
working with people
who don't speak your
language and don't
have that kind of background.
And especially when
you have a legacy
of things like colonialism--
overcoming that is difficult.
So if the people who
have the education and the
power and the privilege
are willing to use it and
publicly support it and go
first, then that, I think,
is a more viable path
forwards than going to
where, frankly, it's
needed most in terms of sheer
human lives and suffering.
So finally, thank you so
much for the invitation,
for the organizers, and
especially to my group
because I'm at
the MIT Media Lab.
We're rewarded for being
controversial and provocative
and all that jazz.
So I can come up here and bash
the current way science is done
and call for change, and
that gets me bonus points.
It doesn't matter how
many scientists I offend.
My tenure committee
will love that.
But my students really
are putting their careers
on the line by sharing
their best ideas in the open
and risking getting
scooped and having they're
promising careers destroyed.
So they are the
real heroes, here.
And so please give them
a round of applause.
[APPLAUSE]
So thank you for your attention.
I'd be happy to take questions.
- Great, thank you.
Wow.
My head is spinning.
This is such brave work.
Thank you very much.
So we are going
to take questions.
If you can line up at the
mic, what I think we will do
is take a couple of questions,
maybe two or three in a row,
and let Kevin sort
of put them together.
And we've got about
I think still--
looks like about 12
minutes for questions.
So I'm sure we're full of them.
Great.
- Hi, my name is Ned Bacon.
I really enjoyed the talk.
Can you just make a few
brief remarks on progress
on specificity and
off-target edits with CRISPR?
Thank you.
- My name is Marci Wells.
And the first thing
that came to my mind
is why can't you give
the ticks birth control?
- Hi, my name is [INAUDIBLE].
And being in
Massachusetts, we're
at the home of
compulsory immunisations,
founded in 1905 in Jacobsen
versus Massachusetts.
I'm just wondering, with
your nuanced approach
to getting community buy-in, if
we were able to go back in time
and change the way
that we approached
immunizations, and done it in a
similar approach to what you're
doing, do you think we'd have a
higher or a lower immunization
rate today?
- [EXHALES]
- My name's Ethel Jackson and
I wonder if you could just give
us a quick update on where
things stand with the release
of gene drive-edited mosquitoes?
I know there's been a lot
of effort along those lines,
and I'd just like to
know where that stands,
in terms of
environmental release?
- OK, so initially,
off-target effects on CRISPR--
So CRISPR is, of course, being
looked at for a lot all sorts
of things.
Its biggest impact
is on research,
just because it makes
everything that we
do in the lab so much easier.
But it's also being
looked at therapeutically
for gene therapy and the like.
And one obvious concern is
you want to program CRISPR
to cut a particular
gene and no other genes,
because if you accidentally cut
a tumor suppressor, that's bad.
If you're doing gene
therapy on a lot of cells
in a lot of patients,
you need to be sure
that you're very, very accurate.
So there's been a
lot of research,
particularly in the
Boston area, by groups
working to make CRISPR
even more specific.
And the best versions now are--
the off-target rate is
pretty close to undetectable.
And that's great,
but just because you
can't detect it doesn't
mean it doesn't exist.
And so if you were
to roll out something
to, say, 50 million
people and you're
altering a billion
cells per person, which
is a tiny fraction of the
cells in an individual's body,
we can't test that many.
So that's why CRISPR will be
great for medical problems
where you're willing to take a
tiny risk of cancer in exchange
for solving an actual problem.
But it's not going to be useful
for but what one might call
a 'recreational' gene therapy.
Tick birth control-- the
preferred form of birth control
is kill them.
So we have lots of-- we
have lots of chemicals
we use to kill ticks.
And they're are concentrated,
of course, on deer.
So there are these four poster
devices where you feed the deer
and it basically rubs
pesticides on the deer
to kill the ticks on them.
There are also these
tubes where you
have Permethrin-treated
cotton balls in the tubes.
You leave them out.
The local mice grab them and
use them for nesting material,
and then burrow into
them in the Permethrin
kills all the ticks on them.
I'm not aware of anyone working
on actual tick contraceptives,
however every couple of
months, I get an email
from someone in
the world, usually
from somewhere in the
United States, who says,
why are you mucking
around with mice?
Just use a suppression
gene drive.
Standard version affects
the entire species
to eliminate all the ticks.
Which you might say, well,
how can a gene drive do that?
Well, there's a couple
of different ways.
The obvious one is
suppose the gene
you're transmitting turns
them all into males?
So I'm skeptical
that you can actually
go all the way to
extinction, certainly
not with a single
drive system, due
to likelihood of
resistance, et cetera.
But one could conceivably
do that except that the tick
generation time is two years.
So if you're willing
to wait a century,
we might be able to do that.
Let's see, next question was
vaccines and immunization
history.
And if we have--
I don't really know on that one.
I know that genetic
engineering in general,
had we started with
something that was actually
a problem that's obvious to
ordinary people as opposed to--
or even played up that
recombinant insulin
is recombinant.
Everyone, raise your hand
if you take insulin--
anyone?
So that insulin, of course,
comes from engineered microbes.
It's recombinant DNA.
It's genetic engineering.
It's GMO.
But most people don't
think of it that way.
We think about
genetic engineering
in the context of Monsanto.
And what do you
all those products
do for the people who
buy them in the market?
a couple of cents cheaper?
That's just not enough.
So that one I know
would be different.
But vaccines, that
was a long time ago
and it's hard to argue
with government control.
And so I really don't know
the answer to that one.
I think that the more we
invite people's voices,
the better off we will be
because things will be safer
and, I think, more acceptable to
people, if people have a voice.
But beyond that, I
couldn't really say.
And as for mosquito
gene drive systems,
there are a number of
laboratories working on them.
There may be some
that I don't know of.
The current status is that
the things that you see
that are published are not--
most of the latest advances
have not been published.
And most of the work,
in fact, everything
other than our
collaborators and my lab--
collaborators
particularly at Harvard
and Flaminia Catteruccia
and George Church's group
in particular.
And we're working with Paul
Brindley at George Washington
University on schistosomiasis
and with Pirbright University,
Luke Alphey in the UK, and
University of Otago [INAUDIBLE]
in New Zealand on rats.
Those are the only projects
that are completely open.
There's a bunch
of mosquito ones.
Target Malaria has results
showing that-- where
they have solved the problem
of the drive system acting
after fertilization.
And this is important if you're
doing the suppression drive
that they're looking for to
reduce the population just
because you need to ensure
that your offspring inherit
one functional copy of a gene.
That's important for fertility.
So if you cut that copy
just after fertilization,
it doesn't work.
And that's been the huge--
it also reduces the efficiency
of the drive system,
so that's been the
number one hurdle.
That one seems to have been
solved in the main malaria
vector species and [INAUDIBLE].
Other problems include to
make it evolutionarily stable,
you have to program CRISPR
to cut many, many sites.
That problem is still
being worked out.
It's one that we're working on.
Once you solve that and
put those two together,
they have enough target
genes that it should work.
What I don't know--
so I think the social side of
'will every African country be
able to agree?'
is going to be the
limiting factor.
There are people working on
that form of gene drive system
and Aedes aegypti.
I think it's a terrible idea.
But, yeah, there's nothing I
can do about that beyond urge
them to be a little bit more
open than what they currently
are.
And see if we can maybe get
the universities around here
to agree to a patent pool
for ethical licensing
to ensure that that work
and all other work is open.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Kevin, thank you very much.
Will you join me in thanking
Kevin for this [INAUDIBLE]..
[APPLAUSE]